thank you
okay just to remind members of this
meeting has been streamed live to
youtube
and i'm also going to um make a
recording of this meeting for the
purposes of the minutes
so just hear a prompt now actually if
you could just start this meeting is
being recorded
thank you and it's all yours chair thank
you very much
everybody welcome to the growth scrutiny
committee today
um we'll start with item one
uh apologies for absence do you have any
apologies
um apologies from the council of migrant
chair
thank you very much for that uh any
declarations of interest
no i'm going to whiz through this aren't
we
item number three uh when it's the last
meeting
to approve as a correct record and the
chair to sign them into the growth
screen
any any issues with the minutes from the
last last meeting for anybody
nope oh so excellent good um
right item number four scrutiny
review um this is triangulation of
evidence
um i think at this point
so if if i could just sort of bring you
into just explain to everybody what
what it's all about i don't know if you
wouldn't mind thank you that's not at
all thank you chair
yes just to remind members um this item
is where we triangulate
all the evidence that you've heard in
connection with your review of tourism
business and non-business a number of
the documents that you've seen
in the year have been attached uh to the
agenda to remind you because obviously
some of this stuff
you looked at several months ago now so
to remind you
um what you've heard including minutes
of each of those meetings because of
course you've also spoke to people as
well
so what we need to get uh for this item
now is your thoughts and conclusions on
what you've heard
with the view to submitting a report to
cabinet of the council uh on your
suggestions
uh regarding this subject now the way
that we usually do that is in three
stages
uh first um and i'll repeat these when
we get to them but i'd ask you
what you think you've heard that
indicates
uh you are working well as a council
in delivering this uh tourism uh area
to the public then i would ask you to
identify items that you think aren't
working so well
other right whether it's perhaps that
we're not doing something you think we
should be doing
we're doing something but you think
we're not doing how you'd like to see it
done and you think we could be smarter
at it
or anything that you just think you
might wish to make a comment on that
might be considered for inclusion in the
report
and arising from that discussion
particularly on what's um
not working so well then to highlight
any possible recommendations you want to
put forward for discussion within the
committee
uh for submission to cabinet um and then
what will happen
at the end of this uh stage i will
obviously make a note of all the things
that you say
uh damon and ash will also be capturing
the debate
and then i will write up over the next
week or so a draft report for you
setting all your thoughts out
in that report which will come back to
the next committee
for you to finalize and make sure it
covers what you want to say to cabinet
about this subject
um and it's you know it's it's there at
the next meeting for discussion in case
you've
missed something or you think something
um perhaps doesn't need to be included
so you know you get a chance to review
what you've discussed and decided
and then finalize your report ready for
submission to cabinet
thank you chair thank you so i will just
say before you before we crack on with
this everybody area
it has been a peculiar year obviously
it's been a peculiar year
and the tourism um stuff
has only sort of really come to us quite
late but i don't want that to
um stop us putting forth stuff forward
even if it's just ideas obviously who's
gonna have to we'll write the report up
for us
but i don't want to just say well we
don't know anything
because of what's happened the there
must be elements of this
um that we can we can comment on
okay um would anyone like to start us
off
any any thoughts anybody
to be honest to have a good look at this
because the other
impacts on my time what i want to say is
i think
caroline has worked incredibly hard with
offices on on this
and i quite like the visitor economy
strategy
that we were saying um yes you're right
there's things that we could
look at differently but this is quite um
an interesting document and i
i do like the way it's been set out but
it's just not all words
um and i think we really need to be
quite positive on moving it forward
yes i think i think you're right i had
just chance
uh well by chance to speak to um jill
cullingham actually about about another
matter on on this
and as soon as she would uh take a
subject a part of
that's part of the tourism thing that
what it is
i want to bring the market back and i
spoke to jill uh
and she pushed she did push
onto one of her officers and they have
contacters within within a couple of
days
so they are actively wanting to promote
tourism within the within the towns
uh so yes i agree with what i've read
i'm i'm quite impressed with it too
nick can i bring you in yeah thanks chad
just
um on that document and i will agree
with what's just been said um you know
it is a good
document um page 16
uh or 27 whichever page numbering we're
looking at
page 27 or 16 um shows weaknesses our
weaknesses
what um obviously without having the
ability to scrutinize all that
what have we mitigated our weaknesses so
we've identified them
either does this document or are there
other things in place
that mitigate and uh and
obviously um create the opportunities we
need to
to reduce our weaknesses or or you know
combat them
i think well i don't know who we asked
that too yeah
i'm not i'm not trying to i'm not going
to be able to answer that question put a
hand up
who's got a hand up sorry sue sorry i'd
like that annoying girl in in
in class aren't who always puts a hand
up i'm so sorry
i know you're my security blanket really
no but
that is a very good question to ask and
in fact it's one of the questions that
uh
i had on my prompt list for you as we go
along through this process
and of course i've had the benefit of
being with the committee for a long time
so i saw the last
two tourism reviews they did and and
that's really is
is the question and i um
some of the things i i thought about
when we were talking about weaknesses
is from the previous review there were
things that
have been suggested then and some work
had been done
but of course with the pandemic a lot of
that has not
necessarily moved on as far as you might
like it
so can i just ask that just ask a few
questions to the committee
and then come back to that question that
council whiteheads raised
and refer it back to what you've heard
and then you might have some opinions on
whether you think some of that has been
actually hit or whether some of it needs
further work
so the questions i would say is is what
we offer to business is it the right
thing
in in the visit economy strategy and
what you've heard from the director
do you think we're doing the right thing
uh for
businesses in terms of tourism in the
district
do you think our engagement is working
well
you know we've heard from a number of
people who aren't directly employed by
the council but
link into our provision of tourism do we
have the right performance indicators in
place to measure the right things
effectively
and some members that worked on the
business center review and will remember
you had a discussion around performance
indicators on that
and asked whether we had the right
indicators to actually know whether what
we was doing
was being effective and i think that
same question applies within this review
whether you think as members you have
the right indicators to tell you whether
you think this has been
done how uh effectively as you'd like it
uh creativity uh
in the uh visitor uh strategy and also
when we've talked about
the growth strategy um connectivity has
been an issue
how well linked is our district
in terms of public transport cycle
networks we had that discussion from the
gentleman andy heath i believe his name
was from dcc
about the cycle trails now interestingly
enough
in the previous scrutiny view this was
an item
was what was on there as not necessarily
um being as strong as you'd like it to
be and obviously we've moved on some but
you heard that stuff
from that officer and also within this
document which may
lead you to a conclusion um
also from the previous review and also
what we've heard raised and also in this
visitor economy document
you've got an issue around identity and
brand
um you know do we have a clear identity
of what we offer in tourism
and you know is it branded are we
getting out what the council has to
offer in this area
and my last one chair how well are we
promoting
um our offer and our businesses that we
have in the area
um so i don't know what that helps in in
you know helping you identify your
thoughts around the question that
council might have
happened sorry yeah i would say i mean
i'm just going back to the brand thing i
i
i don't feel that there is a brand out
there
when you think about the peak district
you
envisage something with no
particularly um so as regards the brand
it's not i won't say it was it was
particularly strong
uh the connectivity we would like to see
with this discussed quite a bit
um
what's a real thing uh nigel
young mew oh i was just found in my
mouth
buried under all my paintings uh
before we start getting into all that
i'm just going back to the opening
remarks
about going through uh you know what's
working well what's not
i just shall we stick to that i'm just
just bring a bit of structure to it and
then
i think if we do what's working well and
then we can come back
one at a time to those i've written them
all down what suits just said
so we're not we're not jumping about
because i thought that the structure is
i think what you said sue was let's
let's identify what's working well
we can do that and and i think the
document's brilliant
uh i like it it's it's it's it's it
does everything it says on the tin uh
and like you say there's been a lot of
work going into it
i think we are we did we agreed to set
on as a council a
tourism officer if we did that's great
i think that's you know all them things
are positive
uh and i i'm happy with those
uh which which i don't know if you if
anybody wants to add anything else about
what's working well
uh and i agree we used to i think
some of those mitigating things that
next you said
we need to then identify how we can
improve on them don't we
if we sort of that i'm just trying to
add a bit of structure to that is that
okay
that's fine i think it's a good idea
yeah
so so as regards the um what's working
well
any comments on that nigel is that what
you want to go with
i say i think we we we're a long way
down
don't track with this this document
aren't we i think
uh there's been a lot away over a lot of
years so aren't they it's not something
that that's that's come out at blue it's
something we have
uh our key when when we were in control
to to sort of build on that we've always
got this problem you know that that
we're not
chesterfield and we're not the peak
district so
we've got a problem with that and now we
fit in with all that
but i do feel we have progressed
uh we know our strengths and as
weaknesses and we've got to work with
them other places aren't we
and both obviously you know we both on
the castle and one of the other
we just haven't got that identity that
others have
so i think this document's a good start
and if
and and setting on the the dedicated
officer will be a real
plus i think that's that's that's my
pluses on the matter yeah i agree i
agree what he's saying
did you have your hand up or was it yeah
i think nick had
up before mine oh
nick would you like to jump in then sir
it would die
it would end up digressed segwaying
across from where we've
just gone to so i'll bring it up uh
later so i think we carry on with um
with the current theme and then yeah i
can bring my points up later
right diana mine were
along similar lines to uh nick um
mainly regarding our weaknesses so we
could move on i do agree with what nigel
said i think our
having the new officer on board is going
to be a great way forward
because at the moment we don't have an
identity
and that's what we need to promote we
need to have an
identity
yeah which is exactly what i was saying
about the brand side of things wasn't it
oh you've frozen oh you might get going
all right
yes thanks um just on the connectivity
and identity what's an interesting point
is how we work together with
other uh councils so you know this is
not for us to be
like lone ranger going out there trying
to get this over the line
um parishes obviously conserve um
you know great partnership um and i'm
not sure what we can do with county as
well but
you know we should be probably talking a
lot more
about that and we talk about
connectivity in that respect with our
partners
so that you know we can have a more
meaningful impact
um together and what it depends which
area um
we look at depends on what kind of
impact that will be anything from killer
marsh has its own kind of
areas for tourism um and could it work
with a parish there
strong field you know all the areas that
where
where we could um have an impact how can
we work with
with our partners i.e other councils
okay thank you lee
yeah i i agree with the the document is
very good it's very clear
and i think it just set out a lot of the
things that we're calling but i think
nick's writing what he's saying there is
that i do think we need to work close
together with
other authorities uh because we bought
the balls over
we bought a ashfield
and we need to link in more with them
and obviously
we cut through chesterfield really a
so all that needs to be linked in and i
think
closer work with all those authorities
ought to be a mainstay or moving it
forward
yeah positive thought yeah i agree then
oh john
jonker bring you answer yeah just just a
few comments really
the document is is pretty decent
it identifies strengths and weaknesses
and opportunities and all the rest of it
that we probably have already knew about
really
i'd be more interested at the promises
that are made in this document
and how they're going to deliver it and
if you look on page 14 he talks about
cattle capital investment to improve the
offer
he talks about creating a festival and
events destination
and he talks about maximizing growth
through tactical marketing
all those three are pretty decent pretty
strong statements
but the council's got to deliver on that
and there's not a lot of substance in
this document of how
and when and who is going to deliver on
the promises that are made in the
document
so that's my only comment it's a nice
document but who's going to deliver it
yeah thank you john i see i i i to see
what you're saying there yeah it's like
it's easy to write stuff down isn't it
but are you gonna are you gonna back it
up
susie you've had your hand up yeah i i
just want to talk about the
the visitor attractions on page three
um i'm like a bit unsure why golf clubs
golf courses are the first thing in the
key and i'm
incredibly disappointed that the five
pits trail
isn't actually named in there that's
for where i live it's it's just a gem
um our kit bag
and although it talks about the william
thorpe nature reserve and home
home homewood woodlands it doesn't
mention
the actual five pits trail which i think
is a bit of a shame
and um i was going to say something
sorry
stupid phones ringing um oh
in answer to john john john funnell's
um question i i do think we're moving
forward
because i've been in one of these
scrutiny meetings
uh about two years ago we talked about
visitor attraction we talked about our
tourism strategy
um and employing a member of staff and
having a statement
is a massive stage forward it's further
than we've got before
so i'm i'm well impressed with where
we're moving in the direction we're
moving in
obviously i wish it had happened five
years ago but it's moving in the right
direction
and i do have to query why we're putting
golf club
golf courses first on this visitor
attraction
and not nature reserves and not cycling
routes because we have that brilliant
guy come in
and talk about how he'd extended the
cycling routes
and what we really need to be thinking
about is what is our usp
and our usp has to be our nature areas
and our um our cycling routes that that
has to be one of the key things
and that helps with the the uh the
climate agenda
in my opinion i i just don't understand
why golf club
courses are it's not alphabetical
you've got attraction it's halfway down
you know why have we prioritized golf
courses i i just find that
an odd thing nick can i
thank you soon i'm with you a little bit
on that
but nick yeah i just i i don't think
this golf course has been prioritized i
don't understand what you're saying suzy
he's probably got
top page he's on the top page i don't
think he's prioritized
and by the way golf is all right i mean
maybe we don't all play it but
um golf is alright and it probably
brings looking at those courses it
brings
thousands and thousands of people people
to um to our area not to mention the
money that they spend so
so it's certainly got a place in there
i'm not sure if it's a priority but i
understand
what you're saying is taking top spot on
the page
yeah john please yeah don't you think
we're in
trouble a little bit with the
attractions if the top two attractions
in our area
are matlock farm park and the center of
england tree in morton
i mean that's not gonna those two on the
attract tourism to the north
derbyshire are they the truth is john
again i'm agreeing with you
totally there because there's there must
be lots and lots of other things
that would perhaps take a priority if
you like as an attraction
above a lot of a lot of these things
there's things in dronefield i think
well
it's not that appealing but maybe
they put in a selection on here and
rather than the actual you know i
don't know diana
going back to some of what's on there i
mean we could all find something to put
on there yeah that's right
but jill did ask for us to actually send
in
to her what we would prioritize
so i think we shouldn't get too bogged
down with what's actually on here
because it is a working document and for
me
i'd put walks and trails at the top
instead of gold but that's
you know me but there you go um
and the events yeah attractions were
very
very attractions but
at the end of the day it's still a
working document
and it's a growing working document so
if there's things we really want to put
on there
let's get them out to jill so the next
time around they are on there
a point well made well made up nick
please
let's just be yeah thank you let's just
be mindful that this is not although
this is a public document this is not a
document that tourists
tourists will be reading no it really
isn't i mean
very few people will read this document
it's obviously important for us as a
working document
but very few people will will use this
document
um so we just need to be mindful that
it's more for information
than anything else um and
and yeah whether there's an element of
prioritization going on i'm not sure i
don't think there is
um but and i think he was right um
saying that we were canvassed about our
opinions and
and flagging up the areas of of interest
so it's only as good as what information
has been passed down as well in that
respect
of course i would say if if you've got
strong feelings which obviously
we have got strong feelings this say
something you just got to say something
and
i'm sure something like this is for
everybody it's not it's not
political uh so it just wants bringing
up
okay right
you've said something about brand so i
presume you'll want some sort of
recommendation
on that you've said something about
connectivity
and identity um
weaknesses yes
uh what i would like sorry what i'd like
to see is we've listed the weaknesses
next to
that list i'd like to see what uh the
mitigating
what are we doing about the weaknesses
is that simple let's not over-complicate
it
it needs a paragraph or more i don't
know how much we go into it but i just i
just want to ensure
that the weakness has been identified
which is great what are we doing about
it
yeah okay sue
yeah and i understand what counselor
whitehead's saying
but obviously the the the power of
scrutiny obviously is the power to
influence through the recommendations
that you've
put um and for those things that are
down there
i would actually make a recommendation
out of them and ask
to have a response within the action
plan that they will do
setting out how they deliver them and
that will mean that each individual one
would actually get a response if you
just say you know we'd like to know what
you're doing about that
it's a very broad thing if you actually
put all of those down
as soon as individual recommendations
then they will have to deliver as part
of that action plan uh
a roadmap for how they're actually going
to deliver each of those recommendations
and that allows you to monitor them over
time so they might
um make good progress on say a couple of
them
which you're very happy with but the
fact that they separated out
you can then track them and then ask
specifically for
and bring an officer in say to update
you on something that you think is not
being developed as quickly as you'd like
to see it i don't know whether that's an
approach that
the uh committee would be happy with
well absolutely i certainly would and
i'm sure just looking around millions
nobody else shaking their heads susie do
you got your hand up sorry can i bring
you in yeah so
sorry just getting my head into to gear
about this and i i
i understand where counselor john funnel
is coming from really because we we need
to also know how much money is
at pitts trail we have an awful lot of
fly tipping
on the five pits trail and we have
limited resources um of the rangers
and the the rangers posts are being
um decimated at the moment we've
about three ranges attached to our area
we've now got about
0.5 of a ranger so if we're gonna
promote this area as a tourist spot we
also need to be
mindful of of keeping it tidy
um and and so when john was saying
i'm assuming i'm paraphrasing on your
behalf here john so you can stop me if
you wish you know
how much are we throwing at this how
much money is going to be dedicated to
this not just
not just a member of staff but are they
going to have their
the ability to sort out problems
in order to raise our profile one of
which i
i believe is is going to be a massive
problem which is fly tipping and the
lack of ranges that we have
oh and can we not have on page 16 can we
not use the junction 29 with the m1
because it is the biggest car park
at five o'clock and at nine o'clock in
the morning
not a good sale hey
that one's okay suzy there's no cars on
there
hardly i know it's
not taken at nine o'clock or at five
o'clock
lee you gotta handle uh
yeah um i would also add
you know a lot of these things that are
highlighted it's a lot of mariah control
we do rely obviously county
own a lot of the land that runs
you know the country parks uh so we're
reliant on them
uh for their commitment as well
so that's a difficult area that
that we need to try and address if we if
at all possible
you know all the routes that go through
they're all alone by dcc
and the rangers are seriously saying
that they're
dcc employees not northeast so
it's difficult to uh want to solve that
yeah and i suppose that goes back to the
connectivity doesn't it really like
making sure that everybody's involved
a little all the message gets across sue
yeah i just
i just wanted to respond to that point
chair
and of course scrutiny when it makes
recommendations
often focuses specifically on the things
that they can directly influence because
that's where you have the power to
change it yourself and take that
decision
however it does have a role in trying to
influence its partners including dcc
and so may make a recommendation or
comment
to whichever partner uh you know
highlighting that you'd like to see
improvement and of course
you know um members have
influence all sorts of ways including
some members who are dcc
and it's about how much pressure people
want to put on to try and get some of
those things to
to work well to help the district
deliver what it wants to deliver
i thank you for that yeah i'm only
speaking about previous reports chair
where we've sometimes made
recommendations
which we have no influence in the sense
of any real power over
uh but a comment being made or
recommendations made
say to county and county have actually
responded quite positively
and and uh done some things that the
committee were happy that they'd
actually picked up
yeah i would i would like to raise in
that
report then about rangers lack of
rangers it's becoming a massive issue
then
okay thanks susie at least
please yeah just on a positive note we
have managed to unlock some funding
uh that's going to open up one of the
connection pass
through to the uh um
avenue site which is going from the
green asland
uh which has got some funding from big
local and
i was came to council but
going back to the issue with uh
most of these places being owned by
dodge county council it's taken five
years
for that to happen and the funding some
of the funding has been there for
a long time
all right nigel
nigel please i think you're muted
yeah you're muted yeah that's okay i'm
just uh
yeah got it there again i'm trying to
just think yeah i've got a list and i
agree with nate
about the weaknesses i mean there's some
of them that no district capital where
we can't
can't alter that but i think there's
some of those things and they do
i'm looking at the list that sue gave us
at the beginning
and whether we should answer some of
those questions and how do we
i think he said well what do what we
offer businesses is that right i think
that was the first question so
are we you know to help promote
businesses that are
supporting the locally you know the
tourists if you like because one thing
that sticks with me
and and leo back me up there's a little
uh
van started coming to grassmore country
park
it's it's a massive attraction it's only
a little
uh you know one of these you can you can
move about mean coffee they do don't
they
by all account i didn't go yesterday i
wrote five bits but i didn't go down
because they said it was
packed out with people paulsbrook
country park i went there three weeks
ago and
i mean what co if whether it would cover
it saves another matter but there mis
must have been 500 people at paul's book
they were serving coffee
so little things like that are we
offering are which supporting
the businesses that that will help
attract people
uh to to things that that's i don't know
how we put that into a form of words
saying yes or no i don't know
just really and also i think we've
talked about connectivity which is fine
we
i think we're we're all on that but
performance indicators i think you
mentioned as well so and i'm just
wondering
how do we monitor all this and
because it's so it goes back to john's
argument
might be a good document but so what
is the answer is the question
just in response to that chair i'm sure
that arising from this
strategy there will be an action plan
prepared for how they're going to do it
but also that is one of the roles
scrutiny can play because if you as i
say put these in your report
then you will have your own action plan
that cabinet has to provide you within
two
months of receiving the report which you
then monitor in the committee over the
following year to see how well they've
been delivered
yeah all right thank you nick
yeah thank you and yeah i mean just
going back to nigel actually
this document yeah like we say is a good
document and
and so what well the so what actually is
is this is our audit um document
this is the one that we go back to and
we
we every meeting we read through it and
we scrutinize it
in terms of um the plan against actual
um that's what we do with the document
um
obviously be great if we had more
details and stuff like that and that
will come out
but the documents is serves its purpose
in that respect
and and obviously officers and anybody
else even cabinet need to take care with
putting wide-ranging rather than
specific
things in the document because then when
when he does come to scrutiny in audit
um there's too much too much ambiguity
going on
so um i don't particularly see that as a
case
but um that that's what the documents
for you know is for us to use
to to scrutinize and it's for the
officers and everybody else to work
towards
that's what the document's going to be
used for
yeah thank you nick before john
you're dead you had to handle diana yep
um thank you similar lines to work what
nick's saying but i'm just wondering
we're saying it's an action and it's um
to be scrutinized
can we put time limits on
for these action plans to come to the
scrutiny committee
so we can see what performance is
happening
what positive steps are happening when
we need to be
really looking at to move things forward
all right thank you for that sue i'll
come back to you
john i'll come back to you
thank you uh sorry i i think i'm
probably sounding like a broken record
but this is the benefit of your
scrutiny view and the action plan that
will come for this document
because you can uh schedule that into
your timetable and as part of your
scooter review
action plan you can put something around
having regular updates on whatever or
you can
say a specific date but obviously that's
a bit more difficult because
you know there's a lot for them to sort
out for
uh their council to sort out so it might
be difficult to say right we want this
by this date and that but you could put
a broader thing about
you know in six months we'd like to see
an update that demonstrates that this
has been met
that sort of thing that's for you to
work out how you want to word that
but that that's perfectly possible but
you would expect as part of the action
plan that they
because you know strategies always have
usually an action plan that sits behind
them setting out how they will be
how and when they'll be delivered and
which officer is going to
deliver it and so i would imagine that
you'd want that document back as a
matter of course to your committee
to monitor delivery of this strategy but
as i say you can put more specific ones
in your report if you want
thank you sue uh john yeah
i better just put the record straight i
don't i don't think it's a bad report at
all
and i wouldn't i wouldn't bring it it's
all but the point i was trying to make
it it's got a lot of
headline sentences in here the headline
commitment
and the detail is in the well the
information is below that
and i'll just pick three out you're
going to develop a program of support
for business engagement that's great
that's what we want to see
but i'd like to know how you're going to
do it and when you're going to do it
you've got another one work with
partners to create an annual event
well who are the partners what's the
annual event
when are you going to do it so it's
really putting some flesh and it's
building on what susie and
niall probably did before you're taking
it
step at a time but you've got to start
to deliver something
and i would been looking at some of the
comments here that's good words
what's behind it and when is it going to
happen
that was what i was trying to point out
really yeah thank you john i thank you
as nick said earlier and this is not to
answer your question really about
putting flesh on the bones because it's
a working document
then we're going to the the fleshing out
of it i would
i would i would guess nick
yeah just just add to that let's let's
remember this is a strategy
and strategy is top level um and after
strategy comes
the detail maybe smart objectives
um the specifics the measurables
everything's got a time and and uh and
accountability to it
so this is a strategy and yes it and so
it will
it will not include everything that's
needed to be in there that we want to
see
um so let's just be mindful that it is
it is that kind of document
yeah thank you okay folks
where do we go sue can i just turn to
where do we go from here
well enough uh information to write a
draft report for you and then
perhaps when it's down on paper and you
see the things there you can knock it
about more
and and you know finalize it to make it
a bit more exactly what what you want
um just to come on from what uh council
white has said
um you know i might put something in
there about monitoring the
uh action plan that sits behind this
strategy because
exactly it's it's about what comes after
this strategy
as to how it's actually delivered on the
ground and something that you can
actually
measure and make sure is having an
impact
all right thank you thank you yeah yeah
this is this is
obviously the first time i've been the
chair of this this committee
and when i first took it on i thought we
just sat around did a lot of chatting to
be honest that and i thought well it's
not don't seem to be going anywhere
but now it's it's sort of filling out a
little bit and it's sort of
starting to make a little bit of sense
certainly for
such as such as me who's new to it so uh
yeah it's it's it's been a good exercise
so far
um so in that case we will move on to
the next
next item uh oh sorry lee do you want to
add to
going to what john said really this
create a baseline of existing events and
festivals
and promote them to existing channels
should we considering
creating an event in the area
something that's an annual event well i
you know i love that idea tom you know
i'm a bit of an event
i've been pubs and whatever yeah i
create events myself so yeah i like an
event in an area
and something that sticks and you do
year on
you know year on year yeah and people
come for that
like like like the gypsies doping for
example or
i can't think of put the big pop one
down south
so yeah i agree with that nick yeah just
uh
actually a specific conversation has
taken place um
uh about this and um
for killer marsh for example and it was
about um
the parish leading with it and districts
supporting it and this is where
you know how we can work together so you
know
the parishes would be the best people to
lead something like that they know their
village they know their area a lot
better
and and district should support it
whether that's with
um the facilities part of it or
um whether there's any monetary side of
it or officer time or promotion
but but let somebody else lead on on it
so the district
doesn't have to go around the whole
district doing these events
we can we can support the the parishes
with it and we'll get more done
localized in in the areas yeah thank you
diana uh yeah going back to what nick
said um
ringerworth we did as a parish council
reintroduce
our annual carnival event
uh sunday called whatever you will and
it's just
grown from the first journey we get over
a thousand people come
and you know it's quite sad we've not
been able to do it this past year
but we have had support from the
district we haven't relied on them to
actually
do it all for us we got out there and
did it ourselves and
it was led by the parish council and i
think this is what we need to do to work
with them
um there's even funding from dcc to do
this so
yeah i'm a great one for annual events
and it does bring the community together
it does you're right you're right nick
it parish
it's a room it's it's probably the way i
mean i'm trying to
resurrect the the marquis drumfield
markets at the moment
uh and you know give jill calling him a
jew i only contacted friday
and she's already instigated quite a bit
of that already for me so
you're very impressed i'm very impressed
with that and the people who were behind
the market
a room you know a lot more optimistic
about the whole the whole idea
but it's got to start with people with
imagination
right folks um item
number five exclusion of the public
martin
are you there have we got anything to
exclude people for here
sue yes chair the uh partnership report
will contain certain confidential
information
to members so that's why we're going
into private session
and it's under paragraph three of the uh
local government attack 1972.
right okay let me just get martial are
you there martin
right yeah we're we're ready to exclude
if we can please
thank you
you